Speaker 1: There is a fight, literally
a verbal fight happening right now
to be Donald Trump's vice presidential running
mate in 2024. On the one hand, you have radical
and repugnant Republican Congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor GREENE. She's desperate to be Trump's
VP. I told you about that last week. On the
other hand, you have a loser, Carrie Lake,
who simply cannot accept more people voted
for your opponent and you lost and it's over.
They are now engaged in a battle to be Donald
Trump's vice presidential running mate. Let's
start with Carrie Lake, who at the very same event
over the weekend during which we already played
one clip, she said the fight is not over over the
Arizona gubernatorial race. Here's a secret. It's
over. It's over. You've lost. She spent 2 minutes
just sucking up to Trump at that very same event,
making it abundantly clear she is campaigning
to be Trump's VP. Listen to this groveling.
Speaker 2: My second favorite guy stood up on
the stage right up there in beautiful Mar a Lago
and said he's going to run for office again.
And I am so excited. News excited about that.
There he is. And I will tell you this right
now, I don't know what my future holds other
than I'm going to continue to fight for
this country. But I will do everything
in my power to make sure this man gets back in
the White House. We need him now more than ever.
There's no other option. There's nobody better
for the job. There's nobody who can get us out
of this nightmare that we're in than somebody who
introduced America First policies. And so I ask
you, in the coming days and months and weeks, as
we're hearing, you know, the fake news media talk
that we stand up and protect and push and and do
everything we can to help President Trump in his
move toward the White House. I will do anything
in my power to make sure this man gets in the
White House for our children sake and for our
country sake. Are you guys with us on that? No.
Speaker 1: A lot of campaigning for the guy
who claims he doesn't need anybody's help.
Speaker 2: Really? With how you aware?
So I'm just honored to be here in
the most beautiful place I've ever been Mar
a Lago. And to be here with the people who
are fighting for America.
Speaker 1: More like the
gorgeous place she's ever been.
Speaker 2: Hers policies. The only way we
get out of this mess is the America First policies
that President Trump introduced. We need strong
states and strong governors and strong leaders
from the president right on down to the school
board member. Let me rephrase that. We need strong
leaders from the school board right on up to the
president, most importantly, the school board. So
thank you so much for being here tonight. Thank
you, President Trump, for inspiring all of us,
Mr. President. And we are with you. We've got your
back and we will be with you right until we get
you back in the White House. Thank you so much.
Speaker 1: All right. So that is a please pick
me to be your VP sort of speech. And then as
a reminder, here's Marjorie Taylor GREENE.
She's desperate to be Trump's pick for 2024,
and she's concerned that DeSantis and this was
before Carrie Lake last let Lake really serve
a long time as governors and not abandon anybody,
because if they did, it might be Marjorie doesn't
get to be Trump's VP. Listen to this hearing.
Speaker 3: And tries to challenge.
Speaker 4: President Trump as far as being
the Republican nominee for 2024. We feel
like it's political suicide. This is
his party. This is his race to run.
Do you want to share your thoughts on that?
Speaker 5: Absolutely. I think that it's clear
and obvious. President Trump is the people's
choice. He's the one that we elected in 2016.
We reelected him in 2020 and we will elect
him in 2024. What we need in this country,
Brian, is we need strong Republican governors
like Ron DeSantis. We need strong Republican
governors. We need Kerry like to win in Arizona.
We need strong Republican governors to fight,
stay in for eight years and save their states.
Speaker 1: Eight years, just long enough that
they wouldn't be able to either run for president.
If you're talking about DeSantis or be Trump's VP,
if you're talking about Carrie Lake.
Speaker 5: Not to abandon their states and try
to run for president or any other big position.
Speaker 1: Could she be any more obvious in
what she's trying to do? The last
thing we need I mean, for the party,
right? For the movement. But for the movement,
the best thing would be DeSantis should be
governor multiple more times. Carrie Lake
should be governor for close to a decade.
They should not try to run for president.
She's campaigning for herself as VP. Only
a Trump supporter would see PRI marrying Trump
as an act of betrayal. And this is going to be
extraordinary. Once it gets going, let me know
what you think. Make sure you're subscribed on
YouTube at YouTube.com slash The David
Pakman Show. Much more coming up today